- Give me that thing before somebody gets-
(gun firing)
(upbeat percussion music)
- I don't think so.
(Keya grunting)
(gun firing)
(hose spraying)
(fighter yelling)
(elbow smashing)
- Ah.
(foot thumping)
(explosion booming)
(helicopter whirring)
(blows thudding)
(fighters grunting)
(glass breaking)
(fighter grunting)
(metal clanging)
(blows thudding)
(fighters grunting)
(bullets whizzing)
(engine humming)
(upbeat music)
(engine revving)
(gun firing)
(Rachel grunting)
(people screaming)
(bomb exploding)
(glass shattering)
(fighters grunting)
(guns firing)
(Rachel grunting)
(electronic beeping)
- Okay, let's cut, let's cut. let's cut.
(blows thudding)
(fighters grunting)
(tires squealing)
(engine revving)
(Rachel grunting)
(bike crashing)
(tires squealing)
(guns firing)
(bike crashing)
(fighters grunting)
(glass breaking)
(body slamming)
(intense music)
(parachute opening)
(Rachel grunting)
(water splashing)
(upbeat electronic music)
(blows thudding)
(fighters grunting)
(gun firing)
(gunfire popping)
(upbeat music)
- Woo!
(upbeat electronic music)